会社ちっちゃかったけど僕は変わらないん
だよ。チャレンジをし続けながら必死に
なって自分の理想に近づこうと思って
もがき苦しみながらこの仕事の基準を自分
が下げちゃうとそのレベルにあった人しか
集められないんだよ。そりいくら人数増え
たってダめですよ。青木サの人学100
回聞いたら豊かになる話。
今回は経営に関するテーマでして、
独立後組織化するために必要なことは何かについて教えてください。
[音楽]
シンプルに、ま、その方はまだ独立したばかりで、え、人材がまだね、採用もまだできてない。これから採用し、組織化するってことだよね。
まずそれはお仕事の内容によっても多少
変わるんですけれども、ま、私は自分が
どういう風にしてきたか、ま、社員5名、
資本金500万で、ま、スタートして今日
まで、ま、一応200今40名の正社員に
なりましたけれども、ま、グループ従業員
は270名を超える。ま、38年経営をし
てきて、今そういう経営ができるように
なりました。
あの、1番最初はね、やっぱり人も
なかなか選べないんですよ。だ、理想と
現実のギャップがあってね、最初の10名
までは厳選して選んだ方が良いんですよ。
最初の10名だけは絶対妥協せずにコスト
がかかっても良い人材を集める。で、最初
から新卒で集めるわけではない。中途採用
でも、ま、援呼とかあとは紹介会社使って
もいいんだけれども、ともかく優秀な人材
と働くっていうのが基本です。でもこれは
理想なんだよね。で、私はあのうちの息子
もね起業したんで、それを彼に教えて、彼
はその通りやりました。でも私は自分が
できたかって言うと僕は自分のそばにいた
5人の身近な人と一緒に独立をしてしまい
ました。で、今もう38年経って一緒に
働いてる1人ね、ま、梅沢君という
メンバーはもう定年迎えて今食卓で一緒に
まだ今も働いてくれています。もう65だ
よね。で最初はじゃあどういうことかと
エコなんですよ。ただ私の職業だからそれ
は良かったんです。なぜなら僕は専門
職業人の仕事なので私が稼ぎ頭だったん
ですよ。トレーナーであり、講演家であり
だから私自身の作り出す価値、そして私の
作り出してく価値の中で必要な人材がその
周りに集まって最初は等身台の中から一生
懸命やっていて、で、ま、プログラムの
仕入れをしてそれを、ま、販売もしながら
ということで、ある意味ではちょっと
難易度の高い仕事でしたので、私が
やっぱりこう公演なんかで
プレゼンテーションして、え、
アシスタント的に一緒に活動して生み出し
た果実を分かち合う。そんなことで最初
やっていって、最初の10名、15名と
いう風に組織として15人ぐらいなるのに
どうだろうとかすごい年齢使ってんのよ。
会社を創業して20年経って売上10億の
経利益2億の社員50名だったのね。20
年経ってだなんてのはまだ20人もいない
と思いますよ。だその時は新卒業もまだ
できてないっていうのは入ってもやめられ
てしまったりそういうことを繰り返してた
よね。中途採用だったしで、僕自身も未熟
だった面もあって、人事制度もきちっと
整ってなかったし、ただ一生懸命毎日誰
よりも働く、時間の長さで勝って、仕事の
量で買って、密度で勝つ。そういう姿勢で
一生懸命働いて、そして稼いだお金の中
から、ま、新卒採用のができるようになっ
ていった。2004年なので1987年に
創業してで2005年から新卒が入り出し
たんだけど、ま、そん時も僕は新卒の
ノーハを持ってたわけじゃないから4大卒
の子を採用してその子に考えてもらったん
だけどね。まあ、正直最初に入った16人
入って15人あと数年でやめちゃって
2006年もまた16人入ってそっから
また数年で10人に辞めちゃってとか
そんなことも繰り返しながらでもま、
2006年の入社した人間は今、ま、後継
者候補で橋本拓也って今役員になってます
し、2007年にも18人ぐらい入ったの
かな、当時ね。でも今でもどうだろう67
、7人残ってるけどみんな幹部なってます
よね。もう大幹部ですよ。1人は取締まり
にもなってるし。だからチャレンジをし
続けながら
必死になって自分の理想に近づこうと思っ
てもがき苦しみながらで人事制度を作っ
たりいろんなことを努力してやっぱりそう
いういい人材が価値想像
価値を作り出してくれるようになった。で
、ま、結果的に今は、ま、経常利益は
30億近い経常利益の会社になったんだ
けど、でもこれはね、ま、うちの会社って
ノルマもないじゃん。営業に多さる人間が
確信を持てる商品を与えられ、やる気の
出る環境で仕事をすることができ、やる気
のある優秀な人材を次々と採用し、採用し
た人間を1人前に育て上げる仕組みを持ち
、常に企業を整え続けていくっていうこと
を若い時に、あの、このことに気づいたの
ね。で、これを追求してきた結果今なんだ
よ。だ、僕ってね、パターン化してるん
ですよ。で、すごく大事なものをすごく
大事にするタイプ。大切な人、大切なこと
、大切なものだ。すごくシンプルなの。
それをね、言語化する。文字かし、言語
化し。ま、うちの場合は上質の追求って
いう企業理念にして売上の追求じゃないよ
ね。病室の追求我が社は選択のもにした
公品室の人材教育を通して顧客の成果の
想像に貢献し全社員の物信両面の幸福の
追求と社会の平和と繁栄に起与することを
目的する。これは昔も変わってないんだよ
。この理念って後でできたんじゃないのよ
。ほど遠かったの最初。でもこれに向かっ
てど真面目に本気で向かってきた人生なん
だよ。だから理念はすごい優秀というか
その立派あとリし事故を愛せよなんてさ
だらけの一応5000万の在庫持ってんの
に満足喜びより幸福おるみたいな。だその
頃本当言われたもん。青きねお前リタにし
事故を愛せよね。利益は目的の結果である
と切れこと言うなと。お前大学も言って
ないからそんな風に言うんだよと言われた
のある経営者から。でもその言った経営者
今どいないよ。
どっか行っちゃったよ。俺はこの満足より
喜びより幸福いるんだと。立体に停止事故
を愛せよと。まさに、ま、バイブルにある
黄金率を土台に何事でも人々からして
欲しいと望む通りのことを他の人々にも
そのよ選択を世に広めることは不満足な
人間関係が禁するあらゆる不幸をなくする
ことは世の中のためだとさらには
アグローリッチこの成功哲学広めることに
よってみんな豊かになれるんだとそこに
ミッション持って頑張ってきた。だから
会社ちっちゃかったけど僕は変わらないん
だよ。でも最初は全然理想と現実の
ギャップでこんなのよ。だけど僕はブれて
ないんですよ。はっきり言えることは、ま
、価値観のところでそのバイブルと出会っ
たから誠実に来てこうとしたので嘘言うと
か人を裏切るとか約束破るとかそういう
ことは僕はしないだ。
そういう意味では根本にあるものが良いものを追求してきたから良い組織になったんじゃないかなと。ま、ちょっと長くなったけどそんな感じかな。
ありがとうございます。ということはその起業して独立したらすぐにその理念というものを明確に持っておいた方が良い。目的を持っておいた方が良い。
うん。なんであんた経営するのって言われた時の目的。
実はね、若い時に本読んだのよ。で、その
本はね、あのPFドラッカーという計学者
がいるんだけどね。そのPFドラッカーが
12歳の頃、あなたは何によって覚えられ
たいのかと牧士に言われて、ドラカーは
答えられなかったのね。そしたら牧士は君
はまだ若いだからこの質問にすぐに答え
られなくてもしょうがない。だけど君が
50歳になった時にこの質問に明確な答え
を持ってなかったとしたら君は自分の人生
を無駄に来たことになると。これすっごい
インパクトがあったので僕。だから
やっぱり人は目的を持ってどういう人間に
なりたいのかということで生きていくこと
は大事だとそれはずっと思ってたんですよ
。トップセルスマンになりたいと思って
なり、トップマネージャーになりたいと
思ってなり、トップコンサントなりたいと
思ってなり、ちっちゃく独立した資本金
500万社員5名で、でもいつかは世界
最高法と思ってたのよ。いつかはクラウン
と同じだよね。いつかは世界最高峰だよ。
だ、そういう心志しはあったので最初は
理想と現実のギャップはものすごくあった
けど目指してきたことは間違いない。
ま、だから雪だるまの最初核が必要じゃん
。それコロコロ転がしてくと大きくなる
わけじゃん。やっぱりコアにあるものは
やっぱりトップの理想、こういう会社作り
たいっていうやっぱり思いは必要だと思う
よ。ま、正直僕社員可愛いしな。やっぱり
いい人材と一緒に働きたいと思ってきたし
、日本マクドナルドを創業した藤田さんの
本を若い時に読んだんだよね。それいくつ
の時だろう?あれもうすごい若い時読んだ
。そしたら藤田さんは1度も約束を破った
ことのない人間で自分の側金を固めていた
と書いてあったのよ。あ、俺もそういう
組織作りたいなとかすごい基準、自分の中
にある基準は高かったんだと思うのよ。今
でもそうだよね。年齢キャリアは積んでっ
てるけど基準は下がらないもん。だから
やっぱりその基準が高いからトップセルス
、トップマネージャー、トップコンサルト
になってくわけで、この仕事の基準を自分
が下げちゃうとそのレベルにあった人しか
集められないんだよ。それはいくら人数
増えたってダメですよ、やっぱり。だから
、ま、ナポレオンヒルはね、配偶者と仲間
として選ぶ人は警戒しろって言ってんのよ
。いや、そうなんだよ。配偶者と仲間とし
て選ぶ人は警戒しなさいって言ってますよ
。それは愛に選んだら結果的に苦労が増え
るってことだよ。ま、これはまた次の
YouTubeで深く話しましょう。はい
。よろしいでしょうか?はい、参考にして
いただければありがたいです。ま、大切な
ものを大切にできるを目指しましょう。
以上です。え、是非ね、コメント欄にも
是非コメントしてください。あとは、え、
チャンネル登録まだの方は是非お願いし
ます。また次回お目に書いたいと思います
。よろしくお願いします。
でもできないんだよ、最初。うん。で、
経験もないし、色々チャレンジをして挫折
もし、痛い思いもしてだけど諦めないで
継続して自分の選択を正解にしてきた人生
なんですよ。本当にそうなの。だから今
うちの幹部って入社した時の
アチューメントではないんですよ。今の
アチューメントは入社した時の
アチューメントなんてのはもう列な会社
ですよ。ブラック企業ですよ。いや、本当
今団連入って当初の議員企業なってどう
いう会入ってるとかありえないですよ。
グレイトプレスワークでね。グランプリ
なんてだから。でもじゃあそれは誰がした
の?僕じゃないよ。社員みんなの力だよ。
でも僕にあるのは理想なんですよ。こう
いう組織を作りたいだ。その理想に共感し
た人間が集まって組織ができてるから。だ
から中心にあるその理想だけはそれが言語
化したり文章化したりするのはそういう
ものだけど思想の中心にあるものは
クオリティだと思う。それともっとズばり
言うと再は必要です。はっきり言ってさが
ないと潰れます会社は。でも長期的反栄は
特人徳の特は才能の際才能のない人間は
独立しちゃダめです。それは迷惑です。
はっきり言うとそうなんだ。だから人に
使われたくないからって独立した人間って
ろな人生来てないですよ。僕はトップ
セルフ、トップマネージャーだから。
トップコンサルタントだから元々は優秀な
んだよ。だ、簡単に言ったらいつも例えで
言うラーメン屋で言うと俺1杯のラーメン
絶対ラーメンチャンピオンになるほど
うまいもの作れる僕が見せ出したから最初
は屋台でいいわけよ。分かる?屋台っての
は全部自分でやるんだから。で、すっごい
並んできてね。大繁盛なって金がいっぱい
溜まってきたからじゃあちっちゃくまず店
で持つかと。そしたらそん時はやっぱり
手足になる子しか集まんないじゃん。別に
で、だんだんだんだん大きくなってってで
、育てた人間にじゃお前店持ってとかって
どんどんどんどん店も出さしてやってで
豊かになってで気がついたら企業体みたい
になったみたいなコアにあるものは
ラーメンへの情熱なんだよ。だから俺も
やっぱり農量開発の情熱は誰にも負けない
よ、本当に。昔はセールスに対する情熱
だったのよ。次はセールスマネージメント
に対する情熱なのよ。次はトレーナーとし
て人材教育に対する情熱なのよ。分かる?
で、今経営に対しても情熱持ってますよ、
今。本当に。だから変わってきたんだ、僕
自身が宿狩りみたいなもんだな。うら
どんどん変いてったもんだよ。でもコアに
あるものはクオリティですよ。それは
変わらないんだよ。だ、昔だって営業教育
のアチュメントなんだもん。最初から今の
アチュメントじゃないもん。上下はないの
でね。うちもそうだったんだから、
やっぱり自分の成長に合わせたお客さんだ
から、お客さんの平均値がうちの会社の
やっぱりポジションなんだよ。ま、営業で
は自信あったから営業教育のアチメントで
等身台で発展してきた。ま、そうやって今
を迎えたとんじゃん
ですね。はい。はい。ありがとうござい
ます。